drew barrymore cannot wait for her
daytime debut she even gave e.t a
virtual tour of her new studio
so here's the question what kind of talk
show host do you think drew's gonna be
well how about the kind of host who
bears it all
including her love life
how much of your life will be
interjected in there
how much have your girls signed off how
much of your dating life will be
well first of all i'm single and my cup
runeth over with my kids so it's really
not on my brain
if gosh forbid i can get some time alone
oh my god
i want it so badly and then would maybe
be a relationship so it's like fifth on
the agenda
i know the line of tmi i'm not
out there to share things in a way that
makes me feel
vulnerable and icky we're definitely
going to discuss
all things relationships on the show
just six more days until drew goes live
from her new studio in new
york city she's been prepping all summer
long but let's be real
drew's been getting ready for this
hosting role all her life
at seven years old i went on a
world tour for e.t and
my whole life changed obviously and i
started
talking with people i don't know very
many kids but i know a lot of growing up
that's the best training i have for this
job is human beings
and my interactions with them drew's
guest list for the premiere week
is stacked reese witherspoon charlize
theron and adam sandler will all be
stopping by plus
a charlie's angels reunion with cameron
diaz and lucy liu
also in studio a news desk and 3d screen
for any virtual visitors
it looks so seamless where someone in
los angeles can come and sit in these
two chairs right here
and have a conversation with me as if
they were right here in the room
we also have people who will come and
sit
in here in person responsibly and safely
here we go everybody
have a great show this is our kitchen
which i could not be more in love with i
did a cooking demo
in here the other day that was like a
true hot mess
and i thought perfect that's exactly
what it looks like when i'm cooking it's
not sexy i'm not like
so anyway having a conversation i'm like
the kitchen's on fire so it can look
beautiful but it can be imperfect
at the same time oh my god it's really
good oh phew
thank god nobody wants to eat a chicken
cutlet and broccoli that is not
happiness
i'm sorry that's just miserable so i
want to find
how we live our lives in a healthy but
realistic and joyful way
i'm so excited i could scream want to do
it with me guys ready
you